I think 60% of mortgages right now are
locked in 4% or less substantial what
are you seeing out there slowdown uh
prices what are you seeing it's
definitely slowed down a lot so what
I've noticed a lot of the smart money it
seems to be either buying real estate in
cash or they're waiting on the sidelines
and I think a lot of people look at real
estate from an investment standpoint and
think why would I buy real estate today
making a six to maybe 7% return When I
could use the same money to buy
treasuries without any work any risk at
52% and sellers are locked in to these
very low mortgages they have very little
incentive to sell if they have a
mortgage that's 4% why would they sell
and replace that with a seven or 8%
mortgage it doesn't make a lot of sense
yeah I could sell my house the price is
still really good but then I got to go
buy a house at 3x or 4X the interest
rate and yeah I could refinance it later
but they're really not thinking that way
they're thinking uh I'm just going to
wait on this a minute yeah